(screaming)
Oh, you too?!
Oh Gosh, dude!
Fuck! Get it out of me!
Get it the FUCK out of me!
I don't know!
What do you want me to do?!
I can't be a mom!
I can't- I don't know how do my laundry,
I'm going to be a terrible FUCKING MOTHER!!!
You're gonna be a great mom.
Don't you fucking lie to me!
You guys!
Is this a joke?
This is-- this is a joke, right?!
This isn't funny!
THIS ISN'T FUNNY!
What THE HELL
IS HAPPENING?!
What's happening?
Reddit is saying little girls,
old women, women in comas...
Ah!
Even all of the animals!
They're all pregnant!
Ugh, gross!
Okay, okay, but why is this happening?
Why is this fucking happening?
Ugh!
Oh my fucking God, you guys!
Oh my God? Was that my water?!
This is my water! Sit down
Oh my God, it's coming out!
It's not coming out, is it?!
NOTHING MAKES SENSE ANYMORE!
What do I do!? What do I do?
Just breathe, breathe!
(screaming)
OH, IT FUCKING HURTS, DUDE!
IT FUCKING HURTS, BRO!
Just stay calm, okay?
It still takes a while, it could take, like, hours--
(trilling)
What the fuck?
Fuck...
(shutter sound)
What is it?!
Is it-- It's your baby!
Shut up!
Go to it!
I guess, I--
It's kinda fucking cute, right?
Hi...
Hi, baby...
(Crunching and screaming)
(burp)
(screaming)
♫ Pregnapocalypse ♪
♪ Is this how it all goes down? ♪
♫ Can we turn this shit arround? ♪
and baby aliens ♪
Oh God!
♫ Baby aliens ♪
♪Who would have thought♪
♪♪
♫ Baby alien ♪